what I'm going to do here is I am going
to do two things which will help me
graph this okay number one the easy
thing like it don't even factorize yeah
so I want to notice where are the roots
and then secondly to know exactly where
it goes like that's what hits the actors
but what about up and down okay where am
I going positive negative i'm going to
use Fatima's to help me okay so can
someone tell me just read and trade off
where the roots of this polynomial to a
month to pay for perfect okay so I've
got one too there's one and then I've
got one two three four- happy times okay
now i'm going to do my factoid thank you
okay because I know that's where the
access but what about up and down okay
so i'm going to draw my factory okay the
first one is X minus 2 where is that go
that's uh that's that's they're all
going up like this and it's going to be
the one that passes through here you see
that X minus 2 if like y equals x which
passes through the origin but it's a bit
lower you see that I sort of pushed it
down so that's fine now x plus 4 be
careful there's eight plus four and this
it's possible again right so this is a
little bit unusual but there are two
factors and they sit on the same spot
okay they both passed through negative 4
over here somebody drew one and then I'm
going to draw another one all right on
top of it ok I know they look separate
but I have to draw them apart so I can
tell that they're to do okay they
actually pass through sorry the same
point they're the same line okay all
right now I want to take my factor light
a little draw some vertical lines
through the places where the factors
change their sign okay and now we're
ready so on the left over here I've got
two negatives and another negative three
negatives what do I get from three
negatives it's negative rights i'm going
to be underneath the axis over here okay
so
that means then I cross over what
happened to you I've got to positive and
a negative to positive so the sign of
the result the product will be also
negative so I'm still down here in this
region ok last one I cross over here and
I've got three and they're all positive
1 2 3 or positive to positive times
positive times positive is positive so
bill I'm up here ok have a look at your
one two three regions you've got to pass
through there but you also have to hit
these intercepts right so watch I've got
to be down here yeah I can't come from
up here it can't be up here because I
just shaken down you you told me I have
to be negative so therefore i guess i'm
doing something like this you see that
you see how I have to stay negative i
also enjoy i'm going to touch and turn
there how do i know that i have to touch
it a bit because it's it's it's a degree
or two right it's a double root very
good so I've got that touching turn I'm
staying down an idiot but now I've gotta
come to you right what kind of R is that
it's a single grid so it's just going to
cut straight through right up and off it
goes and that's it right um this is a
way of trying to get away from thinking
about having to think about the
extremities you need to still understand
that but for these questions you don't
actually need them right the regions
that were shaded using the factor lines
they tell you where to go ok let's have
a look at another one do you pick one
for me pick one of the ones it's been
factorized so anything from be through
to i G do do
ok
all right excellent so you can see the
reason why I asked you to choose a
factor I so honest because now we can
just read the roots straight off where
am I going to cut the x-axis what two
locations 2 and negative 1 I get to from
this one and then move on from that one
okay so negative 1 there and i'll put
two there okay now interesting me you
got you guys chose this one side and do
this but this was interesting how many
factors are there for this actual good
right now it looks like four doesn't it
it looks like four but it's actually
five let me show you why okay um here he
had X minus 2 i'm just count mouth for
you okay i've got x minus 2 and then
i've got x plus 4 and then i have x + 4
again so that's why they were three
factors everything here I'm going to cut
him out i've got x minus 2 i've got x
minus 2 again i've got x plus 1 then i
have x + 1 again but haven't done all is
this guy hanging out the front is a
minus 1 he's a fifth factor okay now i'm
going to draw all of them all okay i'm
going to draw every single one so X
minus 2 and X minus 2 on the same spot
yeah and here I can't draw it you just
enough apart so that consider X plus 1
and X plus 1 they are here and here okay
but then have one more factor negative 1
where does he belong y equals negative 1
is not a line like this is it y equals
negative 1 why cuz they leave one is in
fact a horizontal line right he goes
down here and he's always negative 1 so
he doesn't go up or down he just hangs
out there horizontally okay all right
this has got more factors than before we
can still do that okay i'm going to draw
my dog lines
which is where my factors change side so
over here on the left right how many
factors do I have find them 1 2 3 4 5
they're all negative 5 negative factors
so when you put it all together it's
gonna be negative it's an odd number
isn't it it's on Undine you okay now I
cross over what happens now well I've
got to positive and how many negative 3
negative 1 2 and 3 so 3 negatives is
going to be negative right still need
last one okay I cross over here and I've
got five factors still how many are
positive in having a negative or
positive for positive 1 2 3 4 and then
one is negative this guy down here he
just doesn't care it's just it's done
right so if I've got one negative and
for positives the result will be
negative so in fact interestingly this
particular graph is always negative ok
so now I'm ready to draw this thing
right remember I know what kinds of
bricks these are right they are double
roots so they're going to touch in turn
touch into it so here I mean I've always
get me down for young so I'm going to
start down here and I'm going to touch
turn around right and I've got to come
back up so I can touch and turn around
and that's it there's the graph it never
changes signs always down here ok and so
you can see that's what you're going to
get
um pick another one for me in question
to it can be earlier or later pick
another look hey H that is very original
oh the next one let's give it a shot
write down the equation for me another
straw recette about we got to h okay now
i'm going to use this as my opportunity
to show you that actually I've been
drawing every single factor every single
time but you can save some time i'm
going to show you how so look at this
first things first tell me the
intercepts where does it cut this 4 and
negative 1 good so i'll put negative / 4
1 2 3 4 there and new one there okay so
i know the routes now now just before I
draw the fact alone decided just before
I draw the fat foods or you come back
over here right did you notice because
I've got to fact is sitting on the same
spot do you notice that you've actually
change anything right because I lefty
they're both negative so bet you're not
as positive and Ira here they're both
positive so they're still end up is
positive so they don't actually change
the result at all so therefore this guy
here you see how these X minus 4x minus
4x minus 4 right two of them I can
actually ignore because they don't
change the result right they don't make
it odd or even then just I've got the
same number of negatives or positives
okay so in fact for this guy here
instead of drawing three of them all in
the same spot I just need to draw one
explains all like that
um you can see another way of writing
this is to say this is X minus 4 or
squared times X minus 4x plus 1 okay but
this guy is always positive he'll never
change the sign of what's going on
whatever i multiply this by this is the
important sign that this is why I can
just ignore it okay in terms of positive
or negative okay all right x minus 5
drawing that one x plus one that's there
I've got all the factors i need a draw
my vertical lines okay tell me where i'm
going to go on the left both my factors
are now you just sent my result is
positive I cross over one factor is
positive and the other factor is now you
so my product is negative and then I'm
going to switch over one more time so
now I know where I've got to go okay one
more piece of information I need to know
um I've got two kinds of RIT's going on
here right that's a single group I know
what that does that just cuts through
but then this guy is a triple room so he
does look up through he just comes up to
the axes he pauses and then keep pouring
passes through keeps going the same
direction okay so which one of them is
which this is the single root and this
is the triple room are you okay with
that all right ready let's throw the
dots okay it's going to cut straight
through right there's I've gone from
positive to negative cuts right through
and then here's my triple room so I'm
going to come up to him pause and then
pass through keep going in the same
direction okay you see that was not
difficult at all try and work it out
once you're all the pieces there there's
only one possible thing you can do